thank God my mother is not only you know
beautiful she's brilliant so we came out
from Detroit when uh in summer of 68 for
a two-week vacation
and she ended up getting into UCLA and
getting her master's degree at UCLA in
cinema television production
and because she had gotten her master's
degree and Cinema TV production from
UCLA she was able to go around town and
ask for jobs
and everyone said no no no no a lot of
doors closed and finally she went to NBC
and she said may I please have a job and
they said no we do not have a job here
for you
and she asked a a terrific question she
said do you have an intern program where
I can work for free
and they said no we do not and then she
asked a question that changed our lives
forever she said will you please start
one with me
and they said yes oh my God and so she
got a job wait your mother is the First
NBC intern the other page right she's
one of the first but interns she was the
first intern and then as an intern
working for free she was able to get a
job as a page but but just to as a page
is to give it to her she gave tours of
the studio right and people know them
now because if you've watched on The
Tonight Show or the you know those those
people that wear the the navy jacket
sports jacket and they sometimes used
them on the air but more importantly
that was my mom in 74. but more
importantly the people that got into
that program that your mother invented
ended up being becoming the presidents
of those Studios and you know because
people moved up from intern to page from
page to producer from producer to
president to head of development to head
of the network and head of the studio I
won't bore people at home with who these
people are but a lot of people that you
see on television or the people people
that are making decisions for what you
see on television are people that came
from this program and I had no idea
until right now that that was started
based on a question from your mother
that's exactly right
[Music]